now welcome to this video part 18 of the
pre-war Championship match series now
presenting a game again on the
Challenger Magnus Carlsen and in fact
it's a game that shows some the last
challenger for the world title Boris
Gelfand playing against cards so we have
a nicer meeting of World Championship
challenges this was played in november
two thousand eleven in the towel
memorial and at the time girlfriend
already was the challenger for the 2012
match and yeah Carlton didn't
participate in this cycle and yeah let's
um get to the game playing deform here
Magnus I think I'm not quite sure they
showed any non è four games of his I'm
not quite sure in the series here mostly
place before but still there's also a
good amount of deform this is basically
playing any opening okay delfin now
defense here with the sloth defense he
am has a well I was about to say a
limited repertoire but this is not so
true anymore he introduced the Greenfeld
to his repertoire for the law
championship match and besides the Slav
he can also play the Queens gambit
declined yeah so the Slava was certainly
something to to be expected among the
thing that he had played before total
place III hear them oftentimes called
slows laughs it's indeed a bit slow
blocking this Bishop but it provides a
solid color of the sea for porn and we
see one IDM in the following line galfer
plays Bishop f5 which is one of the main
moves like place is six here then one
idea of this move on is that white has
not yet committed the Knight to c3 and
therefore can also think about setups
like this just to show the general idea
this kind of idea is possible set up
with the night on dicho so that it can
support its colleague only 51 idea of
the c3 move um but Bishop f5 is one of
the main moves assume as mentioned and
now Carlton goes for 93 e6 and night age
form which is a well-known line that has
some very solid reputation for black but
also the reputation of being just a
little bit better for wide this Bishop
is some as hard time to not get
exchanged for for the night in fact
black he has various possibilities to
move the bishop can play should be for
Bishop g4 all of those moves Gavin place
the simplest move just now just to g6
wear white will capture why does not
necessarily need to capture immediately
but Carson goes for that just give me
the bishop Pam and now he played the
Bishop to d3 yeah this is one of the
possibilities not a very common one in
fact the way is playing here is
relatively rare but John it's still an
impossible line but should be 397
castles should be 6 a-3 and this is as
mentioned not so popular for wide simply
because yeah this is an open file
and you have played h3 so on on a very
good day like we'll get to sacrifice on
a tree or maybe push the Jeep on to open
the H file so this is some slightly um
yeah controversial way of playing as
white can easily get under some attack
and we see in the game that indeed this
happened um yeah what should turn black
play here um girl font now decided to UM
yeah clarify things in the center and I
think this is justified he took on see
form what black needs to be cautious
versus that white does not get a
complete clamp on the position let's say
for example a slow move like we need
seven you need to reckon with this kind
of ideas well like cannot play five and
this just push back push back here on
the queenside and the in the near future
also you can ask yourself what is blacks
king doing canceling short does look
wrong castling long even more so so this
is not what black should should do he
took on in the c forum and played in
five oh sorry first is not move and then
he five and this makes sure that there
is no clamping down with there for like
a freeze up his game but on the other
hand of course it looks like the
position will open up and this is
basically what white is looking forward
to because he's got the two bishops and
you'd like to open up the position the
icons now play some a simple-looking but
interesting movie played queen to c 2
and the
is that now black has no one way of
getting Castle short because after short
castles white has a nice shot you can
just capture this pawn the very common
motif in this laughs where the spawns a
double bond is quite often occurring and
the bishop on b3 and the Queen 26 this
is a common Kevin motif so easily
spotted by gafford but those little
ideas can alter the course of the game
the curse know the course of the game
tremendously because now black is
basically forced to cancel long or do
somehow just stay in the center with the
King you can consider a move like this
it's not completely insane you can
continue with Queenie 7 and using this
rook and this rook is in a way developed
but mostly I'm like should try for
cancelling long and this is what galfond
is doing here went for Queenie 7
preparing long castles yep causal played
the little ooh Bishop b2 simply there is
not much much else you could consider
move like f for this is interesting but
takes and long castles seems fine for
black for example after f5 that's just
Bishop c7 attacking here and preparing
this idea so it's not not too great just
Bishop d2 is completely fine yeah now
girl from plate long castles which is by
far the sharpest smooth it done it's
debatable you're not you don't need to
play this but it's just the most
principled way to to go on about
that I'm not quite sure sometimes
galfond in the chest media are just
forums own so yeah has got this kind of
reputation of being a relatively boring
player this is completely untrue i'm not
quite sure where people get to this
conclusion unless you think you need to
sacrifice pieces every game incorrectly
then maybe maybe this is this is right
but he's playing a rather ambitious
chest normally it's not like it's
completely dull especially since he
abandoned petrov for a while he was
playing the Petrov all the time trying
to kill the games black against you for
but now II he's gone back to them um to
the Sicilian mostly and often it's got
very sharp game so he's playing a much
sharper chest than ben Carson for
example no one does criticize him for
playing boring and sometimes you really
plays boring games it's not saying bad
games it's just a very technical chess
and their phones chesus more
enterprising usually so it's really not
justify to call him boring at all okay
so on we see that this is not a boring
game um yeah Carleton Place t5m using
the CFR opposition of queen and a king
and yet this initiates the following
sequence which is very sharp and had to
be evaluated before I'd otherwise white
cannot afford this you should take note
that those pieces are all on the
queenside and whites King side has
really deserted they handle pieces you
know not even look here and let's say
night on f1 and to cover staff or a
bishop on everyone so when we see after
you for this is what galfer plate the
sharpest muth takes and 25 we see that
like is really getting an attack here
you also needed to calculate rook takes
h3 it's not completely crazy I mean it
is but if you need to check it taking
and queen e 5 but white white is got a
phone this is important you can can
easily go for this continuation and this
is not not good at all for black lachann
consider this for a moment and the queen
is trapped this you need to see
beforehand so it played 25 not the
rucksack which is incorrect but this one
has a very important point right now has
no alternative to f4 you know must must
play that otherwise it's a immediate
disaster takes rook takes and now the
very cute move Knight g4 and Calvin who
did annotations himself for this game
admitted that he had overlooked this
move when he played Bishop b2 on the 14
yeah it's an easy to overlook move
because and also there are many
alternatives black also could have
played just check which is not stupid at
all something like this it's a possible
continuation and black has some very
interesting play here it's hard to
assess though possible idea for black is
even to use this look on age 5 get it
down into play in that way however
govern smooth Knight to g4 is perfect
you're right so we don't really need to
look for improvements here um you can
check alternatives but it's not a bad
move we can check what happened Jack
White first took on b7
and King bee idea as usual you want to
play King v8 and not capture on b7
because the king is more exposed here
this is the general consideration in
fact here Queenie for immediately wins
for white so he really needed to play
King b8 yeah and now White has no choice
you need to take this this funky night
take on g4 yeah look edge one check
obviously the point of all this and at
first it looks really really really ugly
for white your course cannot take this
is a chance Nate just a very quick mate
so our King f2 and rook takes a one so
quite quite funny line that now we have
on the board black managed to win the a1
rook with rook h 1 2 A 1 you rarely see
that and yeah how to assess this
position it's obviously really
complicated we see that from a material
point of view White's got six points
Black's code for porn so what is two
pawns for the exchange for being the
exchange down and he's got the b7 porn
and this is always tricky the scan of
porn it can be a decisive factor it can
be just lost and yeah all in all this is
a very unclear position and we see that
it is very difficult also to play ya
cards will now place the move Knight 22
which is probably a strong news it helps
in defense covering g1 maybe intending
Nigeria to cover f1 and it also prepares
to activate the bishop on c3 so this is
probably all right enter Bishop c5 very
natural move getting on this weekend
porn and putting the bishop just
on the sensitive diagonal across the
King dumb causal plays Bishop c3
activating the bishop here on white had
other ideas can also in fact take the
porn it's not out of this world to just
take it but at least to a force sequence
it is it's impossible for a sequence to
take on d to Quinn takes check the ship
takes and now the point check and here
this position will probably end in a
draw though it's still complicated the
King positions are just two to open yeah
y term will always suffer from his King
position and black can hardly make any
progress as long as the be seven points
on the board and yeah well why does
always covering that pawn probably a
draw causal plate bishops III as
mentioned also to to avoid this kind of
draws um another idea was not deform I
must mention that because it nope not
this one threatens threatens 96 but also
would allow a draw and as we know
Carlton um as always trying to keep the
game going and fight the draw is with
rook takes deform tanks and Bichette
eggs yeah and now I'm this is check
check just forced check yeah and no
alternative vm just can't the perpetual
check and the draw yeah Carson always
wants to fight if there's any kind of
possibility to keep the game going and
set problems you will do that so Bishop
dc-3
some Galvan responded to a Queen to e7
perfectly all right and now g5 a good
move fixing those pawns and of course
fixing those pawns is a knife thing but
the position is so complicated it's a
matter of concrete lines yeah what is
the idea if black takes white then plays
Queenie form which is very strong move
it activates the Queen k plus B 7 and if
possible allows Queen F form yeah for
example f5 can't linear form and soundly
white has a very good game all pieces
come to life especially the night
attacking g6 and maybe jumping to e6 so
I'm taking on g5 is probably not really
to the point what galphin plate I think
has some just the most natural moves he
played rook d2 d1 and here we have the
really rare case where black has sort of
doubles on the first rank it really
looks like that the board is set up set
up wrongly if you like that should be
white looks but they're black so black
hair looks on a 1 and D 1 and they
really can yeah can get really annoying
right now look everyone is a big big
threat of course and white really needs
to cover this square on f1 so you went
for 93 and Bishop t6 back trying to
maybe get rid of this defensive piece
yeah causal not played Queenie to again
covering the square and it's the only
move 94 looks attractive at first but
runs into this move yeah some jackets
something like that just just wins the
house we too was caught for any plated
and now look G 1 this is some playable
but a bit risky and probably should
should be punished it seems that the
best move Bishop takes g3 but yeah this
kind of game is always difficult to to
really appreciate if you if you use the
computer for analysis if you look at
this game and you have a computer
running it just helps you the best moves
but play this over the board it's
terribly terribly complicated to
calculate all this Bishop takes 23 m is
some relatively straightforward way to
play though from black probably galphin
also was playing too to find that keep
the game going after this capture you
and rook takes on black and player check
look everyone to simplify things and
something gathered intending Knight to
e5 will probably just equalize the game
but there's also very little that black
can play for you played rock g1 and this
really keeps the game going here on
cousin mr. Jones he played Queen to d3
and it seems that instead Queen B 5 was
the batter booth though this is very
difficult to figure out of course with
the human retina or Li a dumb it is just
a more active move
and it involves lines like greenbee
seven Queenie check 98 and Bishop c4
which again covers this and tries to
activate this Bishop along those lines
for example and that's also look at
seven now and this is completely insane
rook f7 you need to be cautious with g2
is saying via the computer assesses
disposition as winning for white but how
are you going to do that in a game to
recognize that very very difficult I
even have a hard time to understand why
I'd I'll see our bishop f1 as an
additional idea trapping this rook yeah
this is for instance I motif that the
human is simply not not going to see ya
this is a possible line yeah and black
black loses this rule basically if he
takes on g3 in check you take on g1
crazy yeah Queen B 5 was the better move
but 23 years is a human move and it's
not it's not bad in the sense that it
needs to trouble but it's very difficult
to play this game perfectly in fact I
think I'm both players did did an
amazing job in this game too to master
those crazy complications it's
completely crazy trick those two looks
in your camp I would probably suffer
severe problems to play this game I play
this position yeah okay girl from played
Bishop see semiological move keeping
this Bishop out of reach to the Queen
securing it and now night informs plate
it's still it's still a position with
dynamic equality why just missed
something
the was not playing Queen B 5 but it's
still a bit term gets still about equal
disposition on here galphin probably
a.m. yeah I decided on a wrong plan now
by the time it's of course a matter of
remaining time and of course the times
here are nonsense that are shown me and
as you see but galfer seemed seems to be
that he already wasn't slight time
trouble he played we have one it seems
that instead he should just stay you
know like a move like rook h1 continue
and keep the tension he played rock
everyone check obviously trying to
simplify a bit here but this seems to to
work to strengthen White's position
after she takes f3 one point is that he
probably underestimated that the
upcoming moves don't really travel wide
but this is ganna stuff too tough to
evaluate he played f5 yeah and now queen
edge them this is obviously what he
calculated he was thinking about
entering the game with the Queen it's
not a blunder or anything I've heard
this was obviously planned but it seems
that it's really not a big deal and cars
in our place perfectly played Queen to
be five the move that he had missed a
couple of moose earlier now I'm is again
very strong it intense 28 amongst others
and the trees d3 for the king this is in
fact the the key point it seems that the
next month now loses girlfriend played
the GG to check with them the somewhat
crazy looking move from a six he had me
he could try to keep on resisting but
probably a.m. it wouldn't have been
enough to to save the game after a six
Queen a six there's this counter play
and this is enough for a draw so a six
is a cute trick black however check also
must check this move and this is in fact
the best move after this check black gum
takes can check and then Quincy six
attending this killing checkmate only
seven so but so black needs to go for
that check and this of course is a very
tough end game to play White has got two
pawns for the exchange excellent bishops
and this is an additional weakness
probably am like will lose the same game
but it's still a way to resist check he
played the rook check and now white can
simply go forward with the king king d3
not being afraid of any ghosts black
does not even have a check here the only
check is Queen d7 now this is in fact
what was played black has no real
alternative as Queen ADA's such a deadly
threat check so went here yeah and now
the funny point Bishop g5 this pawn
which all the time seemed doomed and
just a just question of time until it is
falling is now the decisive factor note
how nicely White's pieces coordinate
these bishops cover the pawns night
covering the bishop everything's working
nicely together and even the King on d3
player plays a useful role
yeah Gavin plate and Bishop b5 now um if
he captures on f6 there's this threat so
on he needs to move the egg 1 and after
Janice check white can push the upon
with decisive effect no way to stop both
of those pawns yay plate Bishop to g5
and yeah here clouds an it factor also
probably being a bit short on time plays
that in precise move the easiest win now
watch a CAPTCHA check and play King me
form after 97 there's Bishop c6 and this
is the decisive move as some after night
move and it's hard to suggest anything
else there's night c5 coming and 96's
even a checkmate threat at the moment
black has no way to prevent her the porn
from promoting this would have worked
one easily he played another which looks
really cute f form but it's um it's not
the best one here black could have put a
stronger resistance but being short on
time he played the bishop to c7 which
immediately loses he could have played
still Bishop takes Knight eggs obviously
attacking the rook very funny maneuver
but here in fact black can continue on
with the move Knight see I've check King
bee for it still looks terrible with a
double attack on both pieces but there's
Roxy too and now white some doesn't have
anything better than before Knight takes
and night decided check after which this
pawn before and white is probably
winning anyway but it's still a
continuation of the game the other one
was clearer girl font I've ever played
Bishop c7 near being short on time and
after Bishop to c6 needed to resign yeah
this is nice detect and needs to need to
move or take on f6 and just like before
this is deadly in fact here it's already
a first mate the computer already chosen
made in 6 museum this is the immediate
made thread and black cannot cannot
cover that also after this capture
there's oops not that one still nite
nite moves 27 yeah 97 as as deadly here
no way from black to prevent that a very
nice and complicated game showing that
Carlton is an excellent calculator it's
not only Graydon in end games as we saw
before but also excellent in in
calculating complicated positions he
didn't really intend to come under such
heavy fire but really kept a cool head
especially if you consider this kind of
position where those rocks are invading
why its position you can easily um yeah
make a mistake and yeah get-get
checkmated even quickly as can easily
happen if the opponent's pieces are so
active yeah I hope you enjoyed this game
very complicated game and get lonely two
games left in this series and we are
approaching the match itself so not only
a couple of days um ahead to the first
game is played and I will provide of
course
daily game of the day coverage I will
not be able to do any any live coverage
simply because of the time difference
which means that most of the games will
be played when i'm at work in the office
so yeah thanks for watching and I'll be
back tomorrow with the part 19